et dès le début de cette partie sport
turn over en plateau avec de nouvelles
personnes qui sont sur ce plateau il y a
donc toujours Jacques Boine le président
du mlgp mais vous a été rejoint par
Baptiste l'amery bonsoir capitaine de
l'équipe senior du MLS GP et aussi vous
évoluez donc au poste de 2000 mêlés en
face de vous notre journaliste sport du
soir Nicolas dandry bonsoir TV 78 on
parle du MLS GP oui parce que le melegp
ça s'est assuré depuis hier va évoluer
la saison prochaine en fédéral 2 alors
si vous me le permettez si le président
me le permet les mensonaux Saint-Germain
nous ici à qui veut rejoindre Versailles
et plaisir la crème du rugby yvelinois
les clubs des Yvelines qui jouent au
plus haut niveau c'est la sixième
division du rugby national français la
nuit a été courte non
surtout quand on voit les images qui
vont s'afficher de l'ambiance qui avait
déjà à la fin du match au début du match
à la fin du match je suppose que la nuit
a été très courte même pour vous les
joueurs
Jacques nous disait tout à l'heure sa
réaction vous au lendemain vous sentez
comment Mathis 13 heureux très heureux
d'avoir réussi à faire remonter le club
en Fédérale 2 et fatigué aussi et alors
cet accession fait suite à cette
victoire contre l'US Cavaillon en 16e de
finale de Fédérale 3 au match aller dans
le Vaucluse vous étiez incliné 17 à 13
on voit les résultats qui s'affichent
lors du match retour hier à domicile
vous l'avez emporté 25 à 18 entre les
deux matchs dans quel état d'esprit vous
étiez parce que vous étiez en retard
comment ça s'est passé cette semaine
entre une victoire de part et d'autre
mais c'est la différence sur les deux
matchs bien sûr qui est qui est pris
mais c'est pour ça que vous êtes
qualifié
on était confiant on était confiant
parce qu'on avait fait un gros match
quand même à Cavaillon et qu'une c'est
assez facile à récupérer et après voilà
on a fait tout ce qui tout ce qu'il
fallait pour pour gagner ce match à la
maison et pouvoir être qualifier la
différence
je pense qu'on a rien lâché on a rien
lâché on a on a su apprendre de notre
défaite de l'année dernière et
ça nous a pas souri la dernière à une
seconde et là on a réussi dernière
seconde à mettre la pénalité qui nous a
refait passer devant et nous nous a
permis de nous qualifier donc je pense
que c'est sur ça c'est ça c'est
l'expérience président Jacob c'est quoi
la force de ce groupe
force de ce groupe c'est que
c'est une bombe de copains alors qui
sont peut-être découvert un peu sur le
tard même tout au long de la saison mais
c'est une bande de copains en fait et
contrairement à d'autres clubs où je
sais enfin d'autres niveaux où on va
dire que l'aspect financier prend
de la place dans le dans la vie de tous
les jours dans un club bah là
aujourd'hui tout le monde est à peu près
sur le même piédestal en fait il y a pas
de il y a pas de star il y a un groupe
en fait donc ça ça gagne en groupe les
gens sont tous au même niveau et je
pense que c'est ce qui fait notre petit
notre petit réussite vous l'avez dit
vous en êtes rendu compte en cette bande
de potes on est rendu compte au cours de
la saison qu'ils étaient vraiment pote
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu une évolution
tout au long de la saison où vous l'avez
senti aussi il y a une montée en
puissance et de monter en puissance il y
a des il y a des relations qui se font
vraiment naturellement on les voit vivre
alors surtout en plus moi j'étais ancien
joueur enfin il y a quelques années je
vois encore avec eux voilà j'ai mis les
crampons au placard mais ça se voit dans
leurs attitudes en fait et d'un point de
vue extérieur on voit une bande de
copains qui révèle vit ensemble et c'est
ce qui fait vraiment avancer le le club
quoi vous confirmez Baptiste vous qui
avez vécu les choses de l'intérieur
aussi on le voit parce que après c'est
tout des petits détails qui qui au début
on va dire qu'on va peut-être rater
quelque part c'est après il y a les
automatismes mais on voit au cours de la
saison qu'on a beaucoup évolué et donc
l'année prochaine retour en Fédérale 2
est-ce que vous vous projetez déjà ou là
il y a encore on va dire l'euphorie de
cette qualification comment comment vous
projetez alors non il y a toujours le
Forex qualification mais il faut déjà y
penser il faut déjà mettre en place tout
ce qu'on va mettre en place si on veut
pas se prendre les pieds dans le tapis
parce qu'on va pas se mentir l'objectif
va être de se maintenir l'année
prochaine fin dans cette Fédérale 2 et
de pas faire l'ascenseur là-dessus
d'arriver à monter et descendre ça
serait bien pour personne donc
l'objectif va être le maintien voir un
peu mieux si on peut se qualifier pour
efficace finale on verra ce qui est à
prendre mais voilà donc non ça commence
tout de suite à prendre des contacts ce
qu'avaient déjà été lancé avant avec des
joueurs avec enfin voilà et
d'encadrement enfin voilà pour renforcer
un petit peu le club mais dans des
niveaux raisonnables on va dire Grégory
ça c'est pour la Fédérale de l'année
prochaine mais il y a une qualification
plutôt à court terme ce week-end vous
allez jouer en terrain neutre ça va être
différent des derniers matchs puisque
les derniers matchs étaient des phases
aller au retour un match à l'extérieur
un match à domicile là vous allez jouer
en terrain neutre et en plus vous
recevez vous allez jouer les périgourdin
de Sarlat c'est costaud dans le
Sud-Ouest non c'est costaud mais on est
très costaud aussi dans la région
parisienne et là maintenant c'est que du
bonus l'objectif il y a plus de pression
là maintenant on joue et on va essayer
d'aller au plus loin justement vous
allez préparer comment ce match de ce
week-end mais comme tous les autres
matchs c'est me lancer c'est match coupe
près c'est un match on gagne on passe
sinon finir on rentre à la maison donc
voilà c'est peut-être le meilleur état
d'esprit c'est ça là on joue plus pour
du bonus et du plaisir et moi j'oublie
pas que hier il y a mon numéro 6 mon
troisième ligne qui m'a promis d'aller
toucher le bout de bois le 25 juin le
jour de mon anniversaire bon c'est
et du coup comptez quand même sur le
soutien du supporter même si c'est sur
terrain neutre il y a comment vous allez
vous organiser pour essayer d'avoir
quand même un contingent avec vous on a
déjà commencé aujourd'hui on a bon bah
réservé le bus pour les joueurs
premièrement et on a déjà mis un quart
de supporters à disposition si on
remplit bien facilement qui encore de la
demande j'en mettrai un deuxième voilà
apprendre à mettre un peu plus parce que
vous savez le lieu ça devrait être vers
château on l'a pas encore officiellement
mais ça devrait être dans la région
c'est à mi distance donc ça devrait être
Châteauroux donc on mettra un bus voir
deux bus de supporters pour voilà bah
continue à faire vivre un petit peu
l'ambiance autour du club juste quand
même pour continuer à se projeter quand
même sur la saison prochaine quand on
voit la saison de Versailles qui comme
vous l'année dernière accéder en
Fédérale 2 depuis la Fédérale 3 on voit
qu'ils sont arrivés jusqu'en PHAs final
c'est quand même prometteur peut-être
pour vous c'est une différence c'est que
Versailles évolue pour la première fois
cette saison en général éral de alors
vous pouvez bosser un retour
bon c'est comme le vélo ça s'oublie pas
les joueurs ont changé c'est plus la
même époque enfin voilà il va falloir se
remettre à la page aussi un petit peu
là-dedans mais ce qui est encourageant
c'est que l'année dernière on jouait
contre Versailles on Fédérale 3
on a eu une victoire chacun et on a fini
à très peu de points de la première
place derrière Versailles alors je pense
est un petit peu supérieur à nous faut
pas le mentir mais on n'est pas si loin
que ça donc pourquoi pas ne suivre le
même chemin que et d'arriver à faire une
belle première saison Fédérale 2 ils
l'ont fait on était à peu près au même
niveau on peut le faire on se souvient
un gros ambiance dans ces derby Vinois
ça a été aussi le cassette saison
Fédérale 2 entre plaisir et Versailles
Rodrigue vous qui suivez le sport
Illinois même si vous êtes plutôt du
côté de football comme pour quel regard
vous portez sur un une telle prestation
telle performance on est toujours très
fier d'avoir des clubs Yvelines au
niveau surtout rugby je trouve que vous
êtes super performance et c'est très
bien donc je pense que c'est dû aussi au
travail de formation qui est fait en
amont
tout à fait son truc comme ça c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure avant
l'émission il y a il y a 550 licenciés
donc dans ces 150 licenciés il y a
tout ce qui est l'école de rugby
d'accord avec nos jeunes aux juniors et
un club a besoin d'une bonne école de
rugby et c'est je pense une chose sur
lequel on doit travailler encore un
petit peu plus si on veut continuer à
avancer et arriver à équilibrer le club
il va falloir mettre un petit peu plus
de moyens sur notre école de rugby parce
que c'est quand même notre premier
vivier pour enfin qu'on a des jumeaux
qui sortent pour renforcer l'équipe
première bah c'est gagné en fait
l'objectif il est là quoi
dernière saison pour moi
l'année prochaine l'année prochaine donc
il y aura une saison pour vous en
Fédérale 2 effectivement on parlait
35 ans d'une formation derrière 35 ans
bon en tout cas merci messieurs bravo
bravo à vous bravo MLS GP pour cette
promotion en Fédérale 2 et on va suivre
la fin de saison on l'espère avec une
arrivée le plus loin possible dans ces
phases finales de Fédérale 3 latina
peut-être avec le morceau de bois sur le
plateau